- It's funny, you know, you spend like,
all of your 20's trying so so
so hard not to get pregnant,
and then when you decide that it's time,
that you wouldn't have any trouble,
because it seems like it's such a threat
when you're like, in your 20's.
(laughter)
- Do you remember how we met?
- We met at a series of parties.
I was like, you're not leaving
until you give me your number.
That was probably four years ago, now?
- [Nathan] We started dating
in May, so, four years ago.
- April.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- One day I saw a picture
of Nathan with a beard,
holding a baby.
And I was like, I think
maybe this is the guy
that I need to have babies with.
We've been living together for
about two and a half years.
When I got pregnant the first time.
- [Nathan] We told our family immediately,
we really were like, oh, it's on,
this is...
- This is happening.
- What could go wrong?
- We had an ultrasound
at about eight weeks,
and the embryo didn't have a heartbeat.
- They said, basically,
there's not a fetus there.
- It was like a total shock,
the ultrasound lady was like,
"Hmm..."
"So, lemme go get the doctor."
- I mean, you know rationally
that what the doctors
told you was true, but I
think part of you is still
trying to figure out the
solution to the problem.
- So I had a D&C, which stands for
dissection and curettage.
I didn't realize that I was
gonna be continuing to bleed
for the next two weeks.
Which was a constant reminder.
I felt like a failure, like I wasn't sure,
why this had to happen to me.
I was so excited to have a baby,
and it was like, where do we go from here?
But, I did get pregnant again.
- Uh huh.
- But I also had another miscarriage.
And I talked to my doctor about it.
She said, it's a really good sign,
that it means that you
can get pregnant again.
- And then, we did.
- And then we did.
- We did again, after that.
- There was a third miscarriage.
- With each one, two things happened.
The shock of it isn't as extreme,
'cause you've been through it.
But you also start to wonder,
is there something wrong
with our chemistry together?
Is it maybe just isn't gonna happen?
It was a hard time, it was a hard time
for several weeks, months, afterwards.
- All it really took was
one quick Google search,
and I found out that I wasn't alone.
Before I was pregnant the first time,
I didn't really know that many people
who had had miscarriages.
If you don't share with people,
then you don't have a support system.
We had decided to stop trying.
- Yeah.
- After a while.
- And then, two days after
that official choice...
- We found out that I was pregnant.
(laughter)
- Today, I am 18 1/2 weeks pregnant.
We were like, incredibly,
incredibly cautious.
- And we told nobody.
- I refused to believe that it was real,
until I saw a heartbeat.
- There was a lot of anxiety
leading up to the first ultrasound.
- Here we are at the doctor's office,
about to have our NT ultrasound.
And, I just hope that
everything's in the right place.
We went in, and...
- It was real.
- We had a heartbeat.
The genetic counselor called me.
- Right away, on the phonecall,
she was like, "And, do
you want to know the sex?"
Are we gonna find this out right now?
- Oh, my goodness, wow!
Are you ready?
- No, no, yeah.
- And she goes...
- Okay, well it looks like
she has two x chromosomes.
- She!
- Oh my god!
- [Nathan] It was
awesome when we found out
that we are having a baby girl.
- We're having a girl.
(laughter)
- The second ultrasound, we did
another one at 12 weeks ish.
- [Nathan] Yeah, the ultrasound
technician was awesome,
she was like, look there's her
feet, look there's the hands,
there's the face!
And like, printed out
numerous photos for us,
and it was way more fun.
- [Angela] Way more fun.
- [Nathan] Oh my goodness.
- [Angela] Is that her foot, right there?
- [Nathan] There's like, tons of action.
- And that's when we decided
that it was gonna be okay
to tell our families.
- Yeah.
- [Angela] Nathan cut out a
cute little sign that said like,
it's a girl!
- [Nathan] And then we started
this Skype with a monitor
bent down towards us, so
they couldn't see the wall.
And so we kinda hunched down.
- With our faces cut off right here.
- And then at a certain
point, we tried to get
them to say, "Hey, I can't
really see you that well."
- [Angela] Can you see
us okay, or should we...?
- Well, we can see half of Nathan's head.
- Nathan, adjust your, we're
cut off around your eyes.
- The key moment, tilted the screen back,
and then we just kept talking.
- There ya go.
- It's a girl, what does that mean?
- Tilt the screen a little.
- Yeah, there you go, that's good.
Oh, hey, wow!
- We got to see them be like. (sputters)
- Hey, what's goin' on!
(laughter)
- Oh my gosh!
- Oh my god!
- [Nathan] You're a grandpa, or will be.
- [Angela] Almost, I mean.
- [Nathan] Aww.
- It was very fun.
- It was super cute.
I learned a lot during
my first pregnancies.
I guess I just wanna say,
like, for other women
and other couples who
are going through this,
you are not alone.
So, don't be afraid to reach out,
don't be afraid to talk to your families
and your friends about it.
- Stay hopeful, keep your plans intact,
just keep working towards
the result that you need.
- Healthy pregnancies after a miscarriage
are a total possibility.